le collectif nouvelle énergie à magny
les hameaux continue à occuper le
terrain à un peu moins d'un an des
élections municipales sa responsable
roro berger ump a convié samedi matin
chantal jouanno ancienne ministre des
sports du gouvernement fillon
aujourd'hui sénatrice udi de paris pour
une rencontre débat
l'objectif pour nous c'est de rencontrer
lémanique waddell à la rencontre c'est
ce qu'on fait avec une lettre
d'information avec un blog avec du porte
à porte pour aller vers eux et voir
justement quel est le projet qui sera le
plus adapté à ce territoire
donc évidemment le fait de se réunir de
se retrouver lors de ces réunions ça
nous permet aussi de les entendre leurs
préoccupations et de construire
progressivement le projet qui sera porté
par manny nouvelle énergie sport
environnement un programme en
construction au gré des échanges avec la
population et une candidature pas encore
officialisé même si pour celle qui fut
aussi championne de karaté la jeune
conseillère politique de l'ump est déjà
bien rentrés sur le tatami j'aime
beaucoup son combat et son engagement
j'aime bien ses idées parce que ça fait
partie des jeunes pousses enfin c'est
plus une jeune pousse politique
d'ailleurs maintenant qu'ils ont
énormément d'avenir donc
donc c'est pour ça on a besoin toujours
un peu de d'aller soutenir les personnes
en qui on croit c'est nécessaire ump et
udi main dans la main une configuration
que l'on peut donc aisément imaginer
reconduite lors de la constitution des
listes pour les municipales probablement
avant l'été
déjà on n'est pas encore sur la
constitution des listes on n'est pas
encore sûr le temps d investiture ce qui
est sûr c'est que je suis très investi
sur la commune ce qui est sûr c'est que
le jour où on organise vous en serez
informés et en tout cas on s'y prépare
et on se prépare avec ma nouvelle
énergie